nueva era en la lucha antidrogas
el presidente de colombia gustavo petro
propuso a eeuu a hacer cambios profundos
en el trato de narcotraficantes según el
mandatario no en todos los casos deben
ser extraditados
narcotraficante que no negoció con el
estado se va extraditado
narcotraficante que negocie con el
estado y reincida se va extraditado sin
ningún tipo de negociación en los eeuu
narcotraficante que negoció con el
estado colombiano beneficios jurídicos y
deje de ser definitivamente
narcotraficante no se extradita el
mandatario reveló su idea tras la visita
de funcionarios de asuntos
antinarcóticos del gobierno de eeuu a la
capital del país quienes aseguraron que
buscan un nuevo enfoque en la lucha
contra las drogas luego de estas
declaraciones
petro se disponía a viajar al norte del
país sin embargo su visita fue cancelada
luego de que un convoy de avanzada que
inspeccionaba la zona fuera atacado por
grupos irregulares
el hecho se registró en el sector san
pablo el tarra cuando por lo menos seis
sujetos tendrían instalado un retén
ilegal la caravana hizo caso omiso al
padre motivo por el cual fueron
impactados con arma de fuego el ataque
sucedió en una zona de influencia de
grupos ilegales entre ellos el l n con
el que el recién posesionado presidente
ha manifestado intención de retomar
diálogos de paz suspendidos en 2018 hay
expectativa internacional sobre los
contactos del gobierno con esa guerrilla
y este mismo miércoles el presidente del
gobierno español pedro sánchez visitó
bogotá y ofreció su país como sede para
las eventuales negociaciones el gobierno
de colombia tiene la intención de romper
de una vez por todas con el ciclo de
violencia en colombia y en ese empeño lo
único que puedo decir como presidente
del gobierno de españa' es que españa va
a estar siempre de vuestro lado
sánchez ratificó que colombia es un
socio económico de primer orden en
américa latina' y que la región será
prioridad durante la presidencia
española de la unión europea en 2023